hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage we are here all week doing
demos up here various games I'm your
host Mike McCarty here with Nick
margarita
hey what's calling us and someone whose
name comes dangerously close to mine
Mike mehar yep actually fingers doing
odd but you're a producer on NBA Live 18
which EA just showed off at the a press
conference the other day um we saw a few
new things we wanted to dive into but
first off I kind of want to get into
like big-picture stuff like what is it
with NBA Live 18 that you want to do
that 17 didn't and we're like maybe what
did you learn from 17 that you wanted to
kind of push forward into this year well
we've been out like I mean not the hot
topic as we've been out since 16 so we
actually high 16 yeah that's alright so
we we've taken time off to really focus
on two key areas a game play of course
is the you know gameplays King it's what
matters most and then kind of a new way
to play which we're calling the one
which is a remote all about you and your
choices and your character yeah how does
the one gonna work as I saw that like
playing into it seems like maybe like
between Madden's they just announced a
longshot mode and then you have FIFA as
the journey seems like is this NBA is
attempt to kind of get into that like
story driven like progression mode with
the character yeah I think it's a really
great way to describe it
progression mode the focus for us though
I think more me there's some
differentiation between us and are our
brothers in the other sports and our
competitive products are the story
really is yours and so what we're doing
is just kind of crafting this basketball
world where we have your character and
of course your your ability to take a
character into the NBA and get rings and
get MVPs and do all that but also we're
taking a massive component of the
basketball ecosystem in streets and
prolems and a lot of things that NBA
players are doing in the summer and
we're putting that into the game as well
and so the fiction spans both of those
and you can play them interchangeably
and you're the world is aware of what
you're doing in both of those modes you
can do it alone and I think the
interesting part is that you can also do
it some parts of it with co-op and
multiplayer so I noticed what going off
that there are going to be live events
and it's kind of like current events
where you can compete both Solo or Co
in that sense can you talk a little bit
about what those events might be what
they might entail what players might
want to see yeah absolutely it's a great
question that the live events are really
inspired by what we see going on in a
lot of the RPG in an action genre and
what EA Sports does really well with
ultimate team programming and even
mobile for to a certain extent as well
and so what we want to do is all those
good things that is talked about with
your career but post-launch we want to
have these events that kind of make the
game fresh give you things to quest for
co-op get together take on boss's new
courts and we'll time those with
significant events in the NBA calendar
and significant events in I think what
you'd call maybe are the cultural
calendar so big shoe drops and gear
drops and things like that so we put all
that together and it really allows you
to progress your character you know
making keep making your character look
unique buffing it up that type of thing
and so I guess the driving force in
those modes will be what kind of gear
you can earn for your player is that
yeah essentially how it is yeah that
that's that is that really two things
that's 50% it's how you look and how you
play and your swag in your style and
then the other the other 50% of it is
really your skills and your traits one
system that we've put into the game this
year that we've been demoing at EA play
is you have a skill tree for each
character that yours is going to be able
to slightly more unique than my even if
you and I were both shoot first point
guards how you play and how you grow
your shoot first point guard versus mine
will be different the thing we've added
that's really unique that we'd get a lot
of good feedback on so far ta play is a
system called traits and you kind of
think of them as like your loadout so
these things that you can equip
strategically that you earn and you
level up going into game so even though
you're a shoot first point guard or your
position kind of entails that you're
going to play a certain way you can
extend and strategize your abilities in
certain areas with with traits cool so
like those RPG like mechanic you said
you looked at other genres like RPGs in
action like is there attempt to make NBA
Live 18 kind of a more like to gamify
these things to give it like longevity
so like say like apart from like the
hardcore players who were into like NBA
Live 16 like that really just stick to
the franchise now you can kind of bring
in more players who
playing not just for the fun of it but
also for the progression yeah that's a
hard percent exactly what we're trying
to do we really want to lean into what
our players are saying they want most
importantly but also what is we see are
the current trends in gaming right we
want to make sure that we're reflecting
back what players in on how players are
playing so we got a team up and well
team down in Orlando working on this who
are super passionate about basketball
like first and foremost but we're also a
diverse group of gamers we play
everything and we want to take on the
best elements of those things and
deliver it to the basketball gamers yeah
and then I guess to kind of go into the
more what we saw from the past
conference we saw like it talked about
like the street games of the character
factoring into their overall career
still there was like showed a few
cutscenes if I'm not mistaken of them
like playing on the street how does that
factor into their professional career
and their advancement through that
well it'll factor in a couple ways one
what you earn that like for example we
talked about traits I'll use as an
example or even your example of gear
there'll be certain things that are
earned and unlocked in the kind of the
streets mode way of play whether it be
single-player co-op and then when you
earn those things you can kind of take
them and you can apply them to your your
your career in the NBA or the league
and vice versa so and the fiction the
characters you interact with so there'll
be certain players you get to in
characters you interact with you talk to
your choices and how you respond and
interact with those characters yours
might vary from mine but they'll also
dictate what some of your objectives are
but those characters are aware of what
you're doing in both those worlds so
they can kind of respond and react to
how you play kind of sound like quest
givers in an RPG almost right yeah I
think it's pretty a similar way to an
NPC in GTA 5 that you might run into
that gives you this kind of like
reaction or mission or something like
that I think that's a it's pretty
accurate for sure so the streets and
professional kind of coexist together in
this kind of connected world even though
they're very separate between streets
and like professional yeah I mean that's
you should you should work force that's
that's a perfect way to describe it that
is exactly the what we what we want that
you just take away is it could you've
said a connected world and it's taking
really what
you know the most fun and the best ways
to play the sports game but specifically
basketball games where I think the the
authenticity and the the desire to be
the best NBA player ever and also all
that the the kind of different variation
of the gameplay you get in the streets
and just putting it together in
connected world that's it that's a
Harper Senate cool Thank You Veni more
questions
I'm also cool is there anything you want
to add Mike that we didn't ask one last
thing we have all our stuff is available
at EA play right now but we have a demo
coming out in August and people will get
to play the one in a certain segment of
the one for the first time in August and
they'll be able to take all their
progression and everything they earn and
unlock they'll be able to take that into
the launch title which we're launching
in September cool
Mike Mahara thanks so much for coming on
the show yeah no problem guys wait how
was your fun if you're watching from
home you can keep watching all of our
demos from here on games lots III stage
we'll have more from NBA Live coming out
throughout the week
I'll have FIFA Madden coming up and we
will see you then